welcome to this video playing Dena meat
from Russia think I need to check this
young had come on who is this our turn
Arthur I to UM Gabrielle Gabrielle young
sorry if I'm screwed this up these two
thousand six hundred returning rated in
over the board chest the good good
moment to again try this opening hope
you don't mind that I play this some
quite often recently i'd like to
experiment with this you're not taking
us really am not not not a test yeah a
few night g3 i can even go h5 which is
not bad ya know he took maybe you was
more thinking about his choice at this
stage
you know well I had presented this
opening in my video series for for the
ICC and I was surprised really am that
it is it's a viable variable choice and
um it's it's playable it's really
playable okay what now somehow I didn't
want that why did I get into this this G
3m is this g3 setup is slightly
problematic ok I have an idea maybe the
Sun completely idiotic Queenie 6 check
now and Bishop age three to get rid of
the bishops probably it is idiotic
oh this is a very direct way to try to
try to punish me for neglecting
development it's also possibly good of
course Quinn f5 may be back here try to
provoke him to take but it can play wii
i can place before you can really do
that job very very critical already this
or it's them steady six don't know this
can get ugly very ugly it is ugly
already
hmm yeah this looks like young I
complete trashing here how many Queen
whoops did I play it's a fifth one well
this bond and nicely night be five if
it's a good move for example now maybe I
can take on c4 if you take place might
be five but yeah even this is
questionable
Queen a 497 might be five or something
while it looks terrible yeah I came
really stumbled into a crappy line here
she three white wants to go with this g3
Bishop g2 business but there's some way
around it for black and one thing I know
it's not the way that I played with kit
because moving the Queen all the time
quindi fibers often valid but to move it
all the time yeah I hard to tell what is
going to play now there are so many I'm
tempting possibilities probably a simple
new flag and a look-see one also is
pretty good I don't really know they
have me maybe I can take but it looks at
looks I are we forfeited hmm yeah I
don't know should I even upload this guy
can I can post i can quickly analyze
here to to to check how wide is now i'm
winning here maybe rookie one this is
what the computer suggests that suggests
it's very difficult to make a move it
wants to play something like this takes
takes should give form right now hmm
yeah something like this it's just it
just sewn development no development at
all oops that was this was this is the
right arrow gap there there then I must
play something else than this 25 v6
business I think even I think there are
ideas like this and this is not so
terrible I'm just preventing castling
but i'm not sure if this is what i
recommended in those videos I hey I
forgot it already it's been a couple of
month yeah okay I hope you enjoyed it
anyway despite the Sun end but it was a
good demonstration how to make use of
development hd5 and see for this is very
instructive gaining the space and also
clearing d4 for the night very good
plane thanks for watching